Some of us like to spend the weekend with a book in his hands
While some prefer to go out and be the center of attention
But from a scientific point of view, is there any advantage of being an introvert or an abstract? Which is better?
The first to describe the idea of ​​the two main trends of personality was the Swiss psychologist Carl Jung
Who invented the terms both introverted and diagonal.
The theory was separated by German psychiatrist Hans Eisenk
Who defined the Antoine and the Apostles with their fundamental excitement.
Diabetics need a low rate of stimulation to do exciting things that physically and mentally weary the introverses to satisfy their desires.
So while the introvert may just ride the bike in a tranquil park
Diastolic may need to go through the sand roads to feel mental satisfaction.
Brain radiation shows that the frontal cortex is denser at the introversion than the extrasensory
Which are linked to deep thinking and planning
Which suggests that extrasimists may be more aggressive than introversists who prefer to think things over
Rather than rushing to do it directly, but because of the tendency of the introversaries to think about something
They are more susceptible to anxiety and depression.
Diabetics respond more strongly to rewards
With brain radiation showing that they have a greater amount of activated dopamine in the equivalent device than the introversion
When you're done and win a gamble game.
Because we are social beings, dopamine is released when we communicate with other humans.
This was especially important for fishers who relied on others to bring food and protection from predators.
However, the human relationship has a greater influence on the simplistic of the introversion.
In fact, the brains of the Epistemes appear to respond more strongly
When showing images of humans' faces compared to images of nature.
But the mind of the introversaries responds similarly to both images.
This does not mean that the introversians feel no excitement when winning
Or they vehemently hate staying around people
But they simply do not feel the same excitement and do not need that amount of communication to feel satisfied.
From a genetic point of view, there may be an evolutionary advantage for each feature.
For example, introductions may hide with margins to avoid predators
While wandering around and discovering extras, giving them preference when food is scarce.
A study of 130 participants found that a person who tends to be an adventurer has two copies of a particular allele gene
Which reinforces the idea that personality traits are partially associated with genes.
Our society is biased in many ways
Where qualities like putting yourself abroad will be appreciated.
Our institutions are usually designed with the simplistic mindset where "teamwork" is common practice in schools and workplaces,
Creating the idea that creativity stems from a social place.
However, because we are social beings instinctively negate the opinions of others is not aware of it
This suggests that brainstorming sessions with others may not always be fruitful.
Neuroscientists have shown that when we do not agree with the group there will be a high activity in the amygdala
It is part of the brain linked to the rejection state.
When we think of aeronautics, we are ashamed and prefer unity
But in fact, introversists may simply prefer proximity talks with one person or a few people rather than many of them.
Moreover, introvers may be better preachers
Since they are known to reflect on ideas rather than abstractions
Who may choose to make hasty decisions.
But you may be "balanced mood"
In the middle between the circles of introversion and extrapolation combining the best of both worlds!
In a recent study involving 340 representatives of the call center with their track record of 3 months.
Non-Antoine or Nefasatin produced the most revenue at $ 208 per hour,
Compared to the average study of $ 138 per hour.
So where do you see yourself? Do you think there is a better feature than the other?
Let us know when you comment below the video. Translation: team translate Autrjim @